[Musique]
ala pirates de dix mille livres dans une
grange de la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet le collectif hélium composé
d'artistes de la vallée de chevreuse
investi cet espace de 170 m² à
l'occasion du festival des mots les
feuilles d'automne l'oeuvre a été
réalisée en deux jours avec six mètres
cubes des ouvrages donné par emmaüs
trappe
interpellées se questionner savoir ce
qu'on fait avec délire savoir ce qu'on
fait ce qu'on peut faire aussi
collectivement c'est très important
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec tout ça et
même avec des vieux livres on peut on
peut créer quelque chose c'est très
intéressant en plus d'hélium les
visiteurs ont également pu voir des
spectacles des ateliers mais également
assister à des tables rondes les 16 et
17 octobre ce dimanche lors antilles on
est venu présenter un livre qui parle
d'un arbre de la forêt de rambouillet
j'avais entendu parler de ce festival et
et puis bah quand l'occasion s'est
présentée de pouvoir y participer y
contribuer et on a bien sûr tout mis en
oeuvre de manière à ce que je puisse y
participer et puis le pouvoir échanger
avec avec mon public un public en plus
de connaisseur puisque il se promène
dans la forêt dans laquelle victor cus
au total le festival attiré plusieurs
centaines de personnes au regard du
succès rencontré les organisateurs
espèrent pérenniser le rendez vous
l'idée c'est que ça continue 1 c'est pas
juste un événement une fois c'est se
donner un rendez-vous maintenant tous
les ans au travers du festival des mots
et puis d'aller en itinérance d'aller à
la rencontre des publics parmi les
publics les organisateurs voudrait
sensibiliser encore plus les scolaires
dans les prochaines éditions et les
inclure dans le projet l'année prochaine
le rendez vous devrait de nouveau se
tenir à la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet